Sounds like there are a lot of positive attributes for the atelier-aramad-ryphachine, higher frequencies, live with harmonic, I have a true-ryphachine.
What determines which particular ryphachine you choose for each particular patient?
Well, when you started and when most people listening to this started with us, the atelier-aramad didn't exist.
So the atelier-aramad is a new ryphachine, and again, the atelier-aramad has just been out the last couple of months.
So, again, I've told people throughout all of my practice for 35 years that I will never make recommendations based upon my loyalty to a company.
I'll only make recommendations based upon my loyalty to my patients.
So, you know, I've been asked to be part of different companies, different nutritional companies, different therapy companies throughout the years.
And I have to respectfully decline because what if something better comes along that I would make recommendations for, but then I'm financially tied to a company.
So, I've never wanted to be financially tied to a company. I want to be tied to my patients well-being and make only recommendations based upon what's best for the patients.
Now, you know the true ryph was bought out recently and they're making changes for the better.
A lot of people think that some changes are not for the better.
That's a matter of opinion. I think there may be some truth in some of that. I still think the true ryph are fantastic machines.
Would I trade in my true ryph for an atelier-aramad? No, I wouldn't.
If I was going to buy another machine right now, what would I buy? The atelier-aramad.
I think the atelier-aramad is superior. And when true ryph hears me say that, they're going to probably be really mad at me because I've been a big purchaser of them.
But if somebody came to me today and said, which machine should I buy? I'm going to say the atelier-aramad.
If they came to me today and said, I really wanted true ryph because my sister had a true ryph and she got better.
I'm not going to argue with them. Let's get you a true ryph then.
So I don't have any qualms about selling a true ryph and supporting true ryph and continuing to support true ryph moving forward.
And I think they're great machines. I think now the second best machine on the market.
Just like what I was just doing true ryph, we were also selling GB 4000.
And if person came to us with the GB 4000, we tried to help them. The problem with the GB 4000, they're not programmable really at all.
But we'd give them advice at how to use it and things like that. I think they're good machines. They have a lot of power, but they're antiquated with their program.
I would seriously antiquate with the program. But so I really pushed people to a true ryph because you could program it.
Now the atelier-aramad and the true ryph are equal in their programmability. The atelier-aramad is superior in that you can do higher frequencies.
You can do 11th harmonic frequencies and there's some other things coming down the road.
Now true ryph, Jacob True ryph said that they're going to upgrade to a new machine.
You told me that this summer, I don't know when that's coming out.
But it's a completely new machine that would enable some of these things. I don't know what else he didn't give me any clues.
What is going to be enabled on that new board that they're going to have for this new machine.
I can't remember what he told me they're going to call it.
But it would require a person to buy the new machine.
We're going to buy a second machine and buy the atelier-aramad.
If you're like, I can't afford a second machine. I just want the best.
Should I sell my true ryph and buy an atelier-aramad?
No, I don't know. I would say no.
You know, all my staff and the true ryph, all my family still has the true ryph.
They're great machines. It's just like, if you came to me and said, I want to get a second one.
Then I'd say, look at the atelier-aramad. You'll have the best of both worlds.
The negative atelier-aramad is a little bigger. It's not going to be as easy to travel with if you're traveling a lot.
That is a negative at the atelier-aramad.
We still are working out some bugs with it.
But I think it's the better machine.